oh
hey girl you here all alone
take it easy with that I'm just looking
for Pepe happy is dead
who are you coming
my name is Paul Sturgis I'm with Nixon
oil
what's going on here didn't the hardware
Master tell you guys I was on my way
my radio's dead
I never thought I seen a guy from the
company again I'm just here to do the
inspection no I know right yeah
a little later huh
you're alone
yeah yeah of course I'm alone
where the hell is everyone
how'd you can hear us
the little motorboat
ah
what
is a family
yes what the hell
[Music]
okay tell me get away from the edge okay
can you not hear me huh
[Music]
what are you doing
why are you doing that stop doing that
is it
what's happening
Mom what's going on I don't know baby
but whole time whole time
where is that coming from that's where
what
[Music]
happy though
babe what are you doing are you here
hey hey there's nothing here
it's okay
you're okay you're okay
oh God
I'll be right there with you okay
what is happening here yeah what
happened what made the boat sink what is
going on
no we do want to know what's happening
what is it
[Music]
okay
no
the black Beamer where are my kids
beautiful
hey I'm carefully slime
here
hey
I wasn't mad at you back there okay
[Music]
goodness
don't try to understand it Widow
just accept that it's real and alive
how long has that thing been out there
I don't know
I lost track of time
and where's the rest of the crew none
some
managed to evacuate others not so lucky
me and Juno were the only ones smart
enough to stay
smart enough
I I I can't get any signal there's no
signal there's no service
come here and I treat him like
Hey listen to me listen to me
it's not your fault you couldn't have
known none of us could
what is that then
some kind of shark
it's not a shark
it's a Megalodon
Wells don't exist
guys I told you to stay inside what are
you doing here look there must be some
other way off this rig do you think
would be here if there was
still working weeks ago
the calls when ignored ignored ignore
what do you mean what about the
satellite fun it was taken with the crew
look if you're gonna ask me questions
about boats phones or some other way of
getting off this damn rig then we're
going to be here for a long time
who's this little guy that's total
tough name for a little dog
don't look him in the island
what you think I made that up
she's not that tough after all huh
coming from the southern leg let's try
to bring the rig down if the southern
leg holds the auxiliary line yes get the
kids downstairs and inside all right I'm
going to figure this out okay
we're going inside what exactly are your
jobs on the rig
I do whatever is needed me and my
Cardinal are trying to keep this hunk of
from falling into the ocean
and mildly all right give me a complete
rundown on Diamante control room
electrical standard satellite the whole
thing run down nothing works that's your
run down
graphs
and how often does this thing hit the
rig
devonio attacks What It Wants What about
the volume zero this police has been
non-stop for the past few months
are you this thing has been leaking this
bad for months
oh those those indexing knowing you all
about it
just wonder why you guys never sent the
resources to fix it
sir
you saw this damage look absurd to you
little
we grew up here
so when we heard about all these
problems this place was having we
transferred back
see all this now
sorry man
if we live to this
I want to gather up all them bigwig
Toro
[Music]
Sports Construction
I don't think you can take much more
punishment nah it's fine she's designed
to withstanding category five
because I feel like they're wearing five
women the auxiliary is still working
there goes the artillery
for now